I want to talk to you briefly about the
latest revelation with regard to Donald
Trump and Pam Bondi and Trump University
I'll remind you that we found out a
month or two ago maybe more like three
months ago that when Florida stopped
investigating Trump University for fraud
right around that time Donald Trump the
Donald Trump foundation made a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar contribution
to the committee the fundraising
committee that was supporting pam
bondi's reelection as Florida Attorney
General absolutely the complete
appearance of utter impropriety and and
corruption collusion and pay to play
it's even worse than we thought because
it's now been revealed and we're linking
to this article on our YouTube channel
that there was actually a three thousand
dollar per person fundraiser for Pam
Bondi who was facing a very difficult
reelection campaign as attorney general
in Florida and the timing of it is just
as suspicious as the donation from the
Donald J Trump foundation even if you
can't definitively prove that there was
pay to play in the same way that you
can't prove that with regard to Hillary
Clinton in the Clinton Foundation there
is every appearance Rachel that there
was definite impropriety here and what's
amazing to me is Donald Trump won't stop
talking about how Hillary Clinton in the
Clinton Foundation and pay to play and
she met with people as Secretary of
State who had donated to the Clinton
Foundation Trump appears to have been
involved in the exact same thing and i
know you have pot calling the kettle
black people in glass houses shouldn't
throw stones whatever phrase you want to
apply to this it seems as though Donald
Trump has as big of a problem as does
Hillary Clinton potentially when it
comes to this well registered nonprofits
you can't use those for campaign funding
and this isn't the first time that he's
done that because he was using his
nonprofit as a slush fund before when he
was trying to give donations to veterans
to say oh I happen to have I have an
election coming up so i'm going to give
you tons and tons of money but i think
that the real issue here is that would
he take these tactics
into the office and saying i'm going to
use inappropriate ways of payment to get
what I want okay answer to question two
absolutely everything that Donald Trump
is doing now is a preview of how he
would be as president but I i love your
naivete Rachel where you go you're not
allowed to use the money from non
profits to fund elections that's wrong
and you should be punished for that
welcome to politics because we've been
saying this for so long and actually
even Trump using the assertion of a
donation to a Veterans organization from
his nonprofit while campaigning for
president even that is the commingling
of non-profit activities and campaigning
and I mean of course you're I'm serve
joking Rachel you're completely right
about your allegation people really
rarely get punished for this and Trump
would be at the top of the list at least
in the this campaign cycle for host who
should be punished for that it is even
worse than we thought he was fine though
by the IRS so that's something was I
didn't know that he was fine by them so
that's that's pretty exciting you learn
something every day and and the IRS of
course not the Federal Elections
Commission but it is something and for
that I applaud the IRS not an
organization that I think I've ever
praised on the program